[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que toutes les histoires contées
par
mois
sont allaités des histoires qui vont
marquer l'histoire
[Musique]
seul enfant
et
la consolidation de toutes les histoires
[Musique]
ce qu'on
sait
l'aspect l'histoire enfants est ce qu il
[Musique]
ya des similitudes
dans la tasse toi lévis
[Musique]
ce profond
c'est la star de ce changement c'est la
mi-2010
tout enfant ça marche hier j'ai pensé
cette information
nous
serons
des poussées les nouveaux
obèses
suivront
le temps se paye
ses enfants elle a dit qu
il était
dans ceux d'enfants
ne joue pas conservé comme ses autres
frères
le même geoff hoon
est tabou free
qui plaisait bien en son temps
6 900 encore salaires
le père des enfants
a décidé
d'avoir un enfant passe de comptes
privés ou des frissons 17 décembre tous
que son challenge
ce profond et
du fangu d'anonymat c'est très dur pour
les canadiens
avec le départ armand qui ne dit mot ses
sept enfants dr
je profitais habillés comme leur nuise à
leur
insu
et des jeux de rang des nouveaux modèles
et il ya un billet elle semble
les enfants d'oublier tout ça démarre
alors enfant
après il m'a dit
que la position d'israël
eurostat d'autres opportunités
d'une passe au dessus de gadji
vous avez deux choix
semble considérer que la dilue des aides
est là pour nariman
soit vous continuez de l'actualité et
unis pour arrêter
parce que la vie est une priorité
ça me semble
sur fond
de vous rencontrer ce que je t'envoie
réalisait des envies et
aux humanités
diverses familles bien connaissent et
dont le père ouvrier du pc de ma
modestie chez
cet enfant à haïti
de l'état et des ses temps forts si les
noms comme ceux d'enfants à lui briser
tous là dessus car lundi 20 sept enfants
de l'eau
se confond n'a jamais mis les balles des
sept enfants en fin d'année elle dévie
d'abord aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
c'est en venant ici
que vous les
cédez mal de fautes
quand vous devez le gazon est
difficile ce n'est pas notre faute
je suis mal de fautes c'est le volet
c'est d'hésitation de guerre c'est notre
gros des situations et d'un autre
international
je leur ai dit où nous allons
je me
suis encore plus
important
c'est le
domaine
de l'art graphique ati nation
sept ans
ils étaient amis
c'est plus le bureau cossu température
comme de qualité dans sa valise et on
n'est pas ici dans le fouloir dans le
baba de vos mouchoirs ou là qui les
locaux font ça dans sa valise
c'est un souffle à ce
que nos villages
que ça au mans j'ai d'un jeune adulte
vous vous trompez c'est yann moix qui
part d'une analyse
et d'une amende ça va je suis pas à 100
mo à une petite de l'autre de couleur
orange cet enfant tu sais le génie du
dessin
déçus pourront
pas nous en a trois
leur but était descendu à sumatra
sixième
le matin et j
il est le nouveau modèle qui ont fui il
m'a fait mal son p diddy
officie
comme que maladie s'est baladé valady
avant ce temps x et son bilan
lundi
si
son père était le plus âgé a décidé plus
beau toute
humanité leucate cozien voitures
alignées au carrefour où se dose de la
roma 6 comment
ces paroles dalmat city a surprise et
comme usine ici
et
de la même année
je t'en fous à logique de moi je rentre
insisté il était la sixième
il est temps qu'il y avait ici des
trotteurs
c'était une jour l'autre d'occasion se
rendait à d'autres séparations il va
tâcher
de l'autisme dans la cas du béninois
et zizou il était intéressante dixième
mais le cadre d un tapis lui
[Musique]
la ville va
faire
[Musique]
10 du grand duché pharmacie
car j'ai dit
souvent
que nous avons atteint
le plateau des 1000 m saisie cet enfant
[Musique]
se comprend dans le monde peut gagner
enfant on lui fait un mort
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'il décidera si papa comme les
titres dav
[Musique]
il avait seulement
que one 103 kg
salé d'ivoire et la lettre même que ça
dure
et la misère et qui devrait s'en sortir
à la barre
fra pour arrêter par acyclovir
sept enfants
je ressors lui ont dit comme les autres
que la vie est d'une opportunité
que les
que les conditions de vie
l'association familiale plutôt palais
des congrès le feraient les
salons coup d'être produites et saveurs
à un visa mulliez a fait le bon choix
un nouveau choix face aux idées et des
papiers
puis au fonds d'élevage
et modéliser un numéro
vert destiné aux
10 m 3 le lycée des graves
émanations
d'un client du
lady diana
j'ai des enfants
[Applaudissements]
je comprends d'une histoire j'ai demandé
de nous avoir testé
qui avait pas besoin
s amedi
il passait de son temps au garage
les lutteurs
je savais
le réalisme à la maison
selon le devoir
elle y
en a
sept enfants et
toute la nuit n'a pas pu
c'est un tout
a décidé le 10 mai vers le tenais ma
moto
il ajouté une voiture
passe aujourd'hui ils
veulent la mouture du prix des petits
mois dans un an
jeantet ça
et c'est vers les allées du lot
de
subventionner
c'est en venant à la ligne rouge onr
ideye dis moi la plus belle des vases ou
sur
deux relève le pays
dit
c'est pas du
jeu
et du monde ou au bénin
c'est déjà pas mal quand même ne veut
pas j'ai reçu un milliard d'euros de
versements
et le mener de
10,3
il ya des bonnes qui font du népal
alors
ils
se confondent
et du nema offrit du début de match
contre masseube elle n'est pas lui mais
heavy
trois nanas et jeunes enfants
et des rôles
relié à des machines
il est interdit ça
[Applaudissements]
je continuais seul cet enfant
était
pourtant interdite
soit à la source
dix
huit enfants
j'ai patiné
iti
que cette maison soit la malbaie nazis
même si
[Musique]
m6
c'était
il est
lui même
[Musique]
jeune bâti raison de l'aide du déficit
public
ce pas nous
et en plus ne pas contre de bons temps
je me dis quand même une grosse ou celle
de raison qu'on se
situe heureuse mais nous avons besoin de
vous dire
nous avons
voulu faire c'est un de mes dix maisons
se défendre
[Musique]
alors j'avais trois enfants
qui vont
coïncider tellement
au guide lorsque
j'étais ceci dit pour parler des
formations de
21 ans avait démenti
j'ai compris
que mon enfance
et des formes
c'est
que déjà la vie qu'ont fait les autres
d'éviter la vie par
destination
laffont 6 barberi
grâce emma
s'édifie jusqu'à
et surtout
plus d'étincelles des coûts
je vous donne uru 10 avant tout passer
dans votre base y
va zen une fois ci j'ai improvisé
phrase est facile
dieu vous y
viva zik
charité
sont enfants cette fois
oui cet enfant est parti
comme le dit pas trop dans les rôles
dans il est ainsi dans une situation de
tgv soleil c'est lui il est là le soleil
vous pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet enfant
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]